>> .
STEVE: WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU PUT
TOGETHER THE DEMOCRAT OPEN
BORDER WITH DRUG
LEGALIZATION?
YOU HAVE A TOTAL CATASTROPHE
AT MASSIVE EXPLOSION OF CRIME
AND VIOLENCE THE MEXICAN
CARTEL BUILD THE VAST ILLEGAL
MARIJUANA INDUSTRY THAT'S IT'S
BEEN HAPPENING RECENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA TO THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALIST HAS PUT TOGETHER A
FANTASTIC DOCUMENT WITH THE
PODCAST THE DAILY CALIFORNIAN
AND THE WORD ON -┘- THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE TOTALLY IGNORED
THE ISSUE.
>> AS I WAS COVERING THE
BORDER ACTUALLY MET
CONGRESSMAN RCS WHO REPRESENTS
DISTRICT 25 HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND MY HOMETOWN IS IN DISTRICT
25 AND SAID THE REASON I'M SO
FOCUSED ON THE BORDER WE HAVE
A COMMUNITY AND WHAT HE SAID
WE HAVE A MEXICAN CARTEL
CRISIS WITH ILLEGAL MARIJUANA
WITH IF NOT FOR HIM A LOT OF
THIS ISSUE WOULD NOT EVEN MAKE
IT TO THE NEWS AND L.A. COUNTY
REALLY DEPENDS ON GARCIA TO
GET FUNDING BY HIGHLIGHTING
THIS ISSUE BRINGING IT TO DC
BUT HE'S BEEN DOING A
FANTASTIC JOB.
STEVE: HERE HE IS NOW
CALIFORNIA CONGRESSMAN MIKE
GARCIA.
I THANK YOU GOT HIS VOTE BUT
TELL US ABOUT IT.
>> I DID NOT BELIEVE IT MYSELF
UNTIL I SAW FIRSTHAND WE WERE
GETTING PHONE CALLS A YEAR AND
A HALF AGO ABOUT THE ILLEGAL
MARIJUANA GROWTH PROPPING UP
DO LANCASTER IN THE NORTHERN
PART OF THE DISTRICT BY THE
DOZEN SO I TOOK A FIGHT WITH
THE L.A. SHERIFF'S AND WHAT A
SAMPLING ME AWAY LITERALLY
HUNDREDS IF NOT OVER AT
THOUSAND IN MANY CASES WERE
OVER AN ACRE SOME AS LARGE AS
TEN OR 20 ACRES AND VERY
ELABORATE MERCIES WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE PIPING HOSES
FOR MILES OUT OF THE
CALIFORNIA AQUEDUCTS SO WHEN
THE STATE WHERE WE HAVE A
MASSIVE DROUGHT TO BE RUN BY
CARTELS AND MANAGED IN FARMED
BY PEOPLE WHO CAME ACROSS THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY AND PAYING
OFF THEIR DEBT SMUGGLED ACROSS
THE BORDER BY THE CARTELS THIS
IS THEIR WAY TO PAY BACK THE
DEBT TERRIBLE IMPACT WE SAW A
LOCAL CONSTITUENT TO BE HELD
AT GUNPOINT PEOPLE STEALING
LOCAL FARMERS WATER AND
THREATENING TO ANNEX THEIR
LAND AND WE FIX THE PROBLEM WE
HELD THE TOWNHALL THE MIDDLE
OF THE DISTRICT WHERE WE HAD
THE CONSTITUENTS COME TO TELL
US WHAT WAS HAPPENING BEEN IN
THE FRONT ROW WE HAD A CARTEL
MEMBER DRESS SIMILAR EXCEPT HE
HAD A HOLSTER AND A
9-MILLIMETER PISTOL LOOKING AT
ME LIKE THIS IS NOT HIS
PROFILE ON -┘- PROBLEM BUT WE
DID REACH OUT TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IMMEDIATELY AND
GOT THEM TO GATHER TO START
ATTACKING PROBLEM AND
$1 MILLION OF FEDERAL GRANT
MONEY DEA AGENTS TO AUGMENT
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO ARE
OVERCAST AND OVERFUNDED
BASICALLY HAMMERING AWAY AND
WE PUT THEM ON A NATIONAL
SPOTLIGHT.
STEVE: THAT SHOWS ONE MEMBER
OF CONGRESS AND WHAT YOU CAN
DO BUT THE FLOW JUST KEEPS
COMING BECAUSE OF THE BORDER
SITUATION.
>> THAT IS EXACTLY THE PROBLEM
AND AS AGGRESSIVE AS WE WERE
WE WERE JUST SQUEEZING THE
BALLOON AND THE CARTELS WERE
SETTING UP SHOP OUTSIDE OF
L.A. COUNTY BECAUSE THAT'S OUR
DISTRICT AND IT CAN GO A LONG
WAY TO HELP US QUITE A BIT OF
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THE ADMINISTRATION
SECURE THE BORDER TO CHOKE OFF
THE FLOW SO WE ARE NOT
INCENTIVIZING THE CARTELS INTO
OUR DISTRICT THAT WOULD BE A
NOVEL IDEA TO HAVE THE
OFFICIALS LOOK OUT FOR US AND
NOT PUT US INTO HARM'S WAY.
STEVE: AND THE IDEA THAT THEY
NEED TO WAIT FOR LEGISLATION
IS A JOKE.
>> WE SEE $2 BILLION WORTH OF
MARIJUANA STREET VALUE A
COUPLE HUNDRED ARRESTS OR FOUR
DOZEN FIREARMS BUT WHEN YOU
COMPARE THAT MARIJUANA PROBLEM
WITH THE FENTANYL ISSUES IT IS
A TEAM PROBLEM AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS AT FAULT FOR
THAT.
>> SO IN CAN TERMS OF CONTROL
OF THE HOUSE HOW IS IT GOING
AND WHAT ARE THE ISSUES
QUICK.
>> IT'S A TIGHT RACE IT ALWAYS
WILL BE I REPRESENT A BLUE
DISTRICT NOT A PURPLE DISTRICT
JOE BIDEN ONE BY 12 PERCENT
FOR THE LAST ELECTION I WON BY
A NARROW MARGIN BUT BECAUSE
PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT ARE
INFORMED ABOUT THE ISSUE IN
THE CANDIDATES AND IN THE END
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF THEY ARE
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN THEY
JUST WANT TO CONTINUE TO
SURVIVE ESPECIALLY IN
CALIFORNIA AND RIGHT NOW THE
ECONOMY IS ON THE FOREFRONT OF
EVERYONE'S MIND LITERALLY
EVERY TOWNHALL HE HAD A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO INFLATION AND THE
COST OF LIVING IN ALL OF THESE
THINGS ON A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT AREA JUST FOR THOSE
IN THE LARGER MISSION FOR ME
IS TO PREVENT THE NATION FROM
BECOMING CALIFORNIA AND THIS
PRESIDENT AND ADMINISTRATION
HAS ADOPTED THIS IS A
BLUEPRINT FOR HIS DOMESTIC
POLICY WE NOW WHY THEY COUNTRY
IS TRENDING THE WAY IT IS.
STEVE: I'M VERY CONFIDENT WE
NEED THIS MAN IN CONGRESS.
THANK YOU AND TO HEAR THE
WHOLE CONVERSATION IT REALLY
IS EYE-OPENING YOU JUST WON'T
BELIEVE IT GO TO MY WEBSITE
AND SIGN UP FOR